so you had a conversation about AI with
Sam Altman of open Ai and with Elon Musk
yeah what was the content of that
conversation what's your vision for sort
of this very highest of
Tech uh which is artificial intelligence
well first of all I have a high regard
for the people I talk to okay and I I
understand that they understand things I
don't understand and I don't pretend to
understand everything but I do
understand one thing I understand that
the AI
is developing at a geometric rate
and mostly in in political life and in
life in general people don't have an
intuitive grasp of geometric growth you
understand things basically in linear
increments uh and the the idea that
you're coming up a ski slope is very
foreign to people so I don't understand
it and they're naturally also
um
um sort of taken aback by it because
what do you do okay so I think the the
there are several conclusions from my
conversations with the with them and
from my uh other observations that I've
been talking about for many years I'm
talking about the need to do this well
the first thing is this
there is no possibility of not entering
AI with full force
secondly there is a need for regulation
third it's not clear there will be
Global regulation fourth uh it's not
clear where it ends up I I certainly
cannot say that now you might say does
it come to control us okay that's a
question does it come to control us
I don't know the answer to that uh
I think that is uh
as one uh observation that I had from
these conversations
is if it does come to control us that's
probably the only chance of having a
universal regulation because I don't see
anyone anyone
deciding to uh you know to uh
avoid the race and and cooperate unless
you have that threat doesn't mean you
can't regulate AI within countries even
without that understanding but it does
mean that there's a limit to regulation
because every country will want to make
sure that it's not uh doesn't give up
competitive Advantage if there is no
Universal regulation
um I think that right now just as you
know 10 years ago I read um
I read a novel I don't read novels but I
was forced to read one by a Scientific
Advisor I read history I read about
economics I read about technology I just
don't read novels okay and this time uh
follow Churchill you know he said fact
is better than Fiction well this fiction
would become fact and it was a book it
was a novel about
a chinese-american future cyber war and
I read the book one sitting called in a
team of experts and I said all right
let's uh let's join Israel into uh one
of the world's five cyber powers and
let's do it very quickly and we did
actually we did we did exactly that
uh I think AI
is bigger than that and related to that
because it'll affect well cyber affects
everything but AI will affect it even
more fundamentally and the joining of
the two could be very powerful so I
think in Israel we have to
we have to do it anyway for security
reasons when we're doing it but I think
what about
what about our databases that are
already very robust on on the medical
records of 98 of our population
why don't we stick a genetic database on
that why don't we do other things that
can bring magical
what seem are seemingly magical cures
and drugs and medical instruments for
that that's one possibility we have it
in as I said in every single field the
conclusion is this we have to move on AI
we are moving on AI just as we moved on
Cyber and I think Israel will be one of
the leading uh one of the leading AI uh
powers in the world the questions I
don't have an answer to Is
where does it go
how much does it eat chew up on on jobs
there's an assumption that I'm not sure
it's true
that all previous the two big uh
previous
Revolutions in The Human Condition
namely the Agricultural Revolution and
the Industrial Revolution
definitely produce more jobs than they
um uh than they consumed okay that is
not obvious to me at all
I mean I could see new jobs creating and
yes I have that you know that comforting
statement
but it's not quite true
because I think on balance they'll
probably consume more jobs many more
jobs than they'll uh create at least in
the short term
and we don't know about the long term no
I don't know about the long term but I
used to have the Comfort being a free
market guy I always said you know we're
going to produce more jobs than you know
buy I don't know limiting certain
government jobs we're actually in
putting out in the market will create
more jobs which obviously happen you
know we had one Telecom company uh a
government company when I said we're
going to you know we're going to create
competition they said you're going to
run us out we're not going to have more
workers yeah they had 13 000 workers
they went down to seven but we created
another forty thousand uh in the other
companies so that was a comforting
thought I always knew that was true okay
not only that I also knew that wealth
would spread by opening up the markets
completely opposite to the uh socialist
and semi-social history that they had
here uh they said you're going to make
the rich richer and the poor poor no and
made everyone richer and actually uh the
people who entered the job market
because of the reforms we did actually
became a lot richer the and the the
lowest the the lower ladders of uh the
socioeconomic uh measure but here's the
point I don't know I don't know that
that we will not have
what uh Elon Musk calls the end of
scarcity
so you'll have the end of scarcity
you'll have enormous productivity
you know very few people are producing
enormous added value
you're going to have to tax that
to pass it to the others okay you're
gonna have to do that that's a political
question I'm not sure how we answer that
what if you attacks and somebody else
doesn't tax you're going to get
everybody to go there that's an issue an
international issue that we constantly
have to deal with and the second
question you have
is
suppose you solve that problem
and you deliver
uh money okay
to those who are not involved in the AI
economy
what do they do
the first question you ask somebody
whom you just met after the polite you
know the polite exchanges is what do you
do right well people Define themselves
by their profession
and it's going to be difficult if you
don't have a profession and you know
people will spend more time
self-searching they'll more time and uh
in the Arts more time and Leisure I
understand that if I have to bet
it will annihilate many more jobs than
it will create and will force a
structural change in our economics in
our economic models and in our politics
uh and I'm not sure where it's going to
go and that's something we have to
respond to at the nation level and just
as a human civilization both the threat
of AI to just
us as a human species and then the
effect on the jobs and like you said
cyber security and what do you think you
think you think it's gonna we're gonna
lose control
no I first of all I do believe maybe
naively that it will create more jobs
than it takes write that down and we'll
check it it's on record and you know we
don't have we don't say we'll check it
after our lifetime no we'll see it in a
few years we'll see in a few years I'm
really concerned about cyber security
and the nature of how that changes with
the power of AI
and in terms of existential threats
I think there will be so much threats
that aren't existential along the way
that that's the thing I'm mostly
concerned about
um versus AI taking complete control and
becoming sort of superseding the human
species uh although that is something
you should consider seriously because of
the exponential growth of its capability
it's exactly the exponential growth
which we understand
uh is before us but we don't really it's
very hard to project forward to really
understand that's right exactly right so
you know I'm so I deal with what I can
where I can affect something I tend not
to worry about things I don't control
because at a certain point you know
there's no point I mean you have to
decide what you're spending your time on
so I think in Practical terms I think
we'll make uh we'll make Israel a
formidable AI power we understand the
limitation of scale computing power
and other things but I think within
those limits I think we can uh make here
this miracle that we move we did in many
other things uh you know we do more with
less I don't care if it's water the
production of water or the production of
energy or the production of knowledge of
the production of cyber capabilities
defense and other uh we just do more uh
with less and I think in AI we're going
to do a lot more uh with uh relatively
small but highly gifted population very
gifted